welcome back to the 20th century in this
ever more digital world where every
megabit counts in the need for speed
beautiful bucolic Maine is slow internet
service here is among the slowest in the
nation with download speeds just forty
percent of what's available in other
cities James firaga is trying to build a
high-tech state-of-the-art dental
practice in Machias a high-speed
internet line runs right outside his
office but it would cost him tens of
thousands to connect rural areas are
always left out in the cold and we're
kind of used to that but the fact is
that it's a place to grow and we can't
grow without connectivity suppose you
want to download this story in New York
with download speeds near 100 50
megabits per second you could have the
whole video in less than eight seconds
in Maine download speeds are closer to
nine megabits per second so if you're
watching in Maine go ahead and wait for
it to load I'll catch up but readily
available broadband is more than an
issue of convenience studies directly
linked new business growth to faster
internet speeds so it comes as no
surprise veins economy ranks among the
nation's slowest Forbes magazine rated
made the worst in the nation to do
business the past four consecutive years
Maine's big problem a small dispersed
rural population and a lack of
investment from the private sector big
providers like Verizon and Google that
are expanding ultra-fast fiber
nationally haven't made it to me high
speed internet exists in the state but
local providers won't make it available
it costs too much to construct the
so-called last mile fiber connections to
homes and businesses it's not that
Private Finance has has not gone into
rural Maine to build very high speed
networks because they have some
nefarious hidden motive it's not only
can you not make a lot of money doing it
you can't make any money doing it main
business leaders say government either
federal or local has to step up they
cite examples like Chattanooga Tennessee
where the municipal funded high-speed
network built into
10 helped attract new tech firms
entrepreneurs and investors the town of
Rockport main wants to try something
similar Rockport partnered with local
provider gwi and the state to fund and
build a 1 gigabit service to businesses
and residents adjacent towns orono and
old town will also tap local tax dollars
and state coffers to build last mile
connections on their own lease them back
to service providers will hope that the
marketplace would do it if they could do
it they likely will not do it on their
own they won't take that risk and yet
it's essential to our growth and
development rockport and orono old town
are small-scale efforts but the hope is
that his broadband access expands so
we'll Maine's economy